we have aspirant they come up with a
special strain that cure is skin cancer
they get it they got to call it the
Adelanto strain Adelanto California
population 32,000 is a little city in
the middle of the desert the kind of
place you pass by without even noticing
on the drive from LA to Vegas like many
cities in sprawling San Bernardino
County it faces severe financial
problems teetering on the edge of
bankruptcy for a time there was even
talk of dissolving Adelanto and
absorbing it into its larger neighbor
Victorville but then Along Came Johnny
Bug Woodard and his big idea I'm sitting
there thinking about this closely on
what would be my solution
everybody talks and complains about this
or that but yet they failed to go the
further distance walk the other mile
down the road and say what would I do
and then it dawned on me - wait a minute
we can be helping a lot of people I
really could use a medication here we
could be taxing on that could be pointed
sales taxes straight into our general
fund Johnny or bug as his friends column
is a shaggy-haired artist who hosts an
annual bluegrass festival because of
woody stock but he's also a former real
estate agent and a tea party Republican
I'm a redneck my long hair don't cover
up my redneck I'm a Republican I'm a
very conservative guy I believe in the
Second Amendment and this self-described
gun-toting conservative decided to make
his foray into politics by running for
Adelanto City Council on a single issue
saving the town from bankruptcy by
legalizing marijuana cultivation I'd
already picked out some property in
Arizona to move my family to Arizona
because I really didn't think I'd be
elected because I mentioned the M word
mention the N word political suicide
you're not
going to get elected well by golly I got
elected at Atlanta's unemployment rate
currently hovering above 10 percent is
92 percent higher than the national
average its economy relies largely on
the three prisons located within city
limits and the massive warehouses that
store and manufacture everything from
windmill turbines to Predator drones
Atlanta's last big play was on
alternative energy but as the solar
bubble went bust
so did the city's budget the City
Council tried remedying the situation by
putting a utility tax hike on the ballot
but the city's financially struggling
citizens voted it down and voted the
entire council and its mayor out and bug
was suddenly in and he had a mandate but
the political fight was not easy
sheriff's apartment didn't like it
correctional didn't like it schools
didn't like it and a few other kind of
people like to just jump on some sort of
political bandwagon is to feel good
didn't like it we had all these various
people attacking us at the same time I
mean our city council meetings sometimes
wouldn't get out till midnight 12:30 in
the morning the other council member
studied the issue
the mayor visited Colorado to check out
their legal pot situation and slowly but
surely everyone came around and
supported Bug's plan the ordinance
passed positioning Adelanto is the first
Southern California city to legalize
marijuana cultivation on a mass scale
where you're sitting in is one of the
warehouses but hopefully by 2017 will
house drains of cannabis that will be
cultivated for the consumer market
Freddie Sage is a defense attorney
specializing in medical marijuana cases
and one of Atlanta's first early
investors as CEO of Adelanto research
technologies he plans to open up
marijuana grow houses in
state-of-the-art laboratories in these
massive warehouses you're looking at
jobs in manufacturing cultivation
security maintenance construction sales
marketing transportation distribution so
you're looking at a whole variety of
economic job so it's not just simply
growing
plant we never took the gamble we would
have never had a chance and you
certainly wouldn't have a chance if you
never took the gamble so it's like what
do you got to lose
okay so magically everything seems to be
falling in place it's almost like the
good Lord is looking down on our little
town in our city council and directing
us it's like I put this on the earth for
you guys use the ordinance requires that
at least 50% of the jobs created in the
area go to citizens of Atlanta well it's
too early to tell if bugs gamble will
pay off for the city he's already seeing
signs of hope in the spike in real
estate prices as investors scramble to
buy up Atlanta's land and obtain
licenses well it's still cheap we watch
this real estate go into the millions of
dollars which is going to come back and
property tax we've given out 29 licenses
25 of them went out in two days
I'd say we're still in a danger zone for
now but the light is really looking much
better every day California's
legislature made a delando's ordinance
possible earlier this year by passing
statewide regulations on medical
cannabis for the first time but the real
long game for Adelanto is statewide
commercial marijuana legalization which
Californians will vote on this November
for years and years our city was treated
like a bad stepchild by all these other
cities and now we have an opportunity if
we do this right we're going to be the
ones that they look to you and go oh wow
we want to be like that town now and
it's going to be a role reversal
you